The biggest threat to Diffie-Hellman
key exchange is the so-called
bucket brigade attack.
It is a kind of
man-in-the-middle attack.
That is Trudy, the adversary,
can intercept the message
you that Alice sends to Bob.
And instead,
Trudy sends her own yx to Bob.
And fooling Bob to accept this as you.
Likewise, Trudy intercepts
Yb that Bob sends to Alice,
and instead sends her own Yx to Alice.
Fooling Alice to believe
that Yx is actually Yb.
And the result is that the shared
key that Alice computes,
is actually the shared key
between Alice and Trudy.
And likewise,
the shared key that Bob computes,
is actually the shared key
between Trudy and Bob.
In other words, Trudy Plays Bob
to Alice, and Alice to Bob.
This man in the middle attack is
possible because the Diffie–Hellman key
exchange protocol does not
authenticate Alice or Bob.
For example, there's no way for
Alice to know that the message that
she receives is really from Bob.
There are a number of ways to fix this.
For example, everyone, for
example, Alice and Bob,
can publish her or
his public key, you or Yx.
That is, instead of having to send it
and risk interception and forgery,
just publish you or
Yb at a public trusted site.
Or, if Alice has already published her
RSA public key, she can signed you when
she sends it to Bob, so that Bob would
know that you is really from Alice.
Because Bob can verify that
uses Alice's RSA public key.